look at you winner you I'm so stoked for
you right now this has to feel like a
top five moment for you now having the
II got status how are you feeling in
this moment it's kind of surreal it's
something I never even thought about
like you know when I started my career I
probably want to win some Grammys and
sell a lot of records and all that
started happening pretty quickly but I
never dreamed that I would be here
winning an Emmy and being in that rare
group of people that have won all four
of these major Academy Awards it's such
a huge honor and I'm just happy I was
part of such a great show it was such a
phenomenal show Jesus Christ Superstar
and the cast got very emotional I know
we dedicated this award to the producer
so talk to me a little bit about that
moment well Craig and I Craig zadan
he passed away just a month ago and he
was one of the producers on this show we
first worked together when Kamen and I
performed glory at the Oscars they
produced that show and and really were
the brains behind the incredible set
design and and just that climactic
moment at the Oscars and so we worked
together then and then we worked
together here for Jesus Christ Superstar
and honestly those are two of the
highlights of my career and for us to
have been able to work together with
Craig and Neil and the whole team on
this was just fantastic and we dedicate
this win to him and she tweeted it out
that she was gonna ugly cry in the crowd
and she definitely did that but she also
stated awhile ago now she has to move
her Spike TV Award we will make room we
have a plenty of room at the house we'll
make room for all the trophies what does
it mean to have her with you here
tonight well she was supposed to be
taping lip-sync battle while we were
here and she convinced her producers to
push the second show back so she could
come here in between shows and see if we
would win this II got and I was hoping
that I would not disappoint her and make
her trip a waste of time so she was very
supportive and I'm glad we made it worth
our while
you